salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
en nuestro estudio está por supuesto la
titular de esta sección más Romero
salamar bienvenida buena mañana de
miércoles vamos a hablar de las
infecciones provocadas por hongos sí
Raúl un tema que tocamos poco y lo vamos
a dedicar la sección porque ayer la
Organización Mundial de la Salud publicó
por primera vez cuál es el listado no de
los 19 hongos más peligrosos para la
salud humana no hay listados parecidos
en los casos de las bacterias también de
los virus pero como es un campo tampoco
estudiado el de los hongos no se había
hecho hasta hoy en día sin embargo pues
se teme que pueda volverse cada vez más
relevante con a cambios Como por ejemplo
el calentamiento global el cambio
climático para entender a las
implicaciones de todo esto estamos con
Óscar Franco director del departamento
de salud pública de la Universidad de
utrecht doctor Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos este lunes estábamos
hablando de esta este miércoles verdad
estamos hablando de la lista esta de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud no
Cuáles son estos hongos y qué provocan
sí antes que eso recordar un poco como
los hongos se transmiten Y es que los
hongos se pueden transmitir de
diferentes formas incluyendo por ejemplo
esporas y estas se pueden inhalar
entonces afecta el sistema respiratorio
o en entrar en contacto y puede afectar
la piel la lista son 19 que mencionan
como de prioridad importante y luego ya
mencionan cuatro específicamente que son
de prioridad crítica que incluyen los
los que son tienen una mayor prevalencia
en el mundo como el asper que los
fumigatos y el candida árbitro Pero
también es la cándida audios y también
está el otro que es el criptococcus
neoformas que es una de las principales
causas de muerte en pacientes con VIH
Estos son como los cuatro principales
pero son 19 los que menciona la lista
doctor los saludo Qué bueno tenerlo
nuevamente nuestro programa que carga de
enfermedad provocan estas infecciones
por hongos
se sorpresivamente los números indican
que es una carga alta más o menos 13 a
14 millones de personas se afectan por
ese tipo de infecciones al año y de
estas 1.5 millones más o menos es lo que
se sabe mueren en la mayoría de estos
son personas que tienen algún compromiso
en su función inmune a pesar de todo
esto a pesar de que afecta el gran
cantidad de personas y que muchas
personas fallecen por esta enfermedades
equivalentes a la tuberculosis por
ejemplo solamente el 1.5% de toda la
inversión mundial en enfermedades
infecciosas está destinada a investigar
cómo tratar y Cómo mejorar la forma en
que estamos abordando Este tipo de
enfermedades hablaba de cómo tratar este
tipo de enfermedades precisamente los
hongos son uno de los organismos que
también han desarrollado resistencia a
los antibióticos a los tratamientos anti
fungicidas no entonces normalmente a
raíz de uno de un mal uso qué riesgo
tiene esto y Qué podemos hacer para
combatirlo también
si tenemos que recordar que no tenemos
más de 100 años con antibióticos y que
los gracias a los antibióticos gracias
al avance de la medicina vemos como
infecciones que en el pasado eran
fatales Ahora son leves o no tienen
realmente un peligro para para la vida
entonces lo que estamos viendo Es una
gran aumento de la resistencia
antimicrobiana antibióticos antifúngicos
Y eso se ha debido al uso inadecuado
mucha automedicación también el uso de
este tipo de medicamentos como
antibióticos en la producción de
alimentos y lo que podríamos es regresar
una a una era en la cual los
antibióticos ya no tienen un efecto
contra los microorganismos y estas
infecciones se pueden hacer nuevamente
fatales doctor porque no se le ha dado
tanta importancia tanta visibilidad a
este tipo de infecciones
por un lado son difíciles de tratar
muchos de los de los medicamentos que se
tratan de desarrollar pueden afectar a
las células del huésped al salir de los
mamíferos que tienen similitudes con las
células de los hongos y por otro lado
por razones económicas estos
medicamentos no solamente son difíciles
de desarrollar de investigar sino que
además cuando se dan se dan Solamente
una vez no como un tratamiento para la
hipertensión arterial que es para toda
la vida y por lo tanto el margen de
ganancia para las compañías
farmacéuticas pues no es muy alto y no
hay grandes incentivos para hacer
investigación en el tema ahora para
terminar también Mirando a futuro no
precisamente una de las cosas de las que
alertaba la OMS era que el cambio
climático podía hacer que estas
enfermedades infecciosas transmitidas
por hongos fueran más prevalentes que
sabemos de esto
si se ha visto durante la pandemia
también que un aumento en infecciones
por hongos esperquilosis vimos soy
mucormicosis el famoso hongo negro que
vimos en India que se estaba afectando
la población durante el aumento de la
variante Delta además de eso el cambio
climático también ha hecho que la
distribución de algunos hongos que
estaban destinados a ciertos lugares
geográficos se haya hecho más amplio
entonces es muy importante continuar
invirtiendo en investigación y frenar
este tipo de infecciones y Cómo afecta
la población como siempre más
investigación la respuesta a muchos de
los problemas que tenemos hoy en día que
podremos tener en el futuro Gracias
doctor o por estar con nosotros en este
espacio de salud de directo América de
Francia 24 y por supuesto gracias a Omar
y nosotros Entonces de esta manera damos
a punto final a salud mañana con más
salud mañana